hi good afternoon
it's really a special pleasure for me
today to be able to introduce craig
mundy to all of you
craig is here
under the auspices of the gordon grand
lecture series which was set up about 40
years ago
actually interesting story gordon grand
was a very distinguished alumnus of yale
college who went on to be a business
leader at the olin corporation and other
enterprises
and in his memory his classmate clint
frank how many people recognize who
clint frank was anybody
he was the yale's heisman trophy winner
in 1937.
um
uh
clint frank gave a gift to endow the
gordon grant lectureship and we've had
for that entire period of time
outstanding business leaders come to
yale to talk to yale college students
when the school of management opened
later in the 1970s the program was
expanded so that usually we can tap
these visitors to go to both
to speak to both yale college students
and to
som students
anyway craig mundy i had the great
pleasure in the i guess we both did in
january 2009 of being appointed by
president obama to the president's
council of advisors on science and
technology
where there are some real scientists and
real technologists and a token economist
and
i
i have i have learned so much from
craig
through his participation in this in in
those meetings he's got an extraordinary
grasp
of the whole range of what technology
can do for the human condition
i'll come back to that craig's history
is that he spent a number of years after
graduating from georgia tech
in the computer industry in a variety of
startup businesses uh
and some bigger ones
and then 1993
he moved to
microsoft where he's been the last 20
years and where his role has been quite
extraordinary for many years
up till just recently he was the chief
strategy chief research and strategy
officer for this technological giant
uh direct
directing
the entirety of microsoft's research
organization and also
the
chief strategist in technology and and
and how you know the approach the
company should take towards the
uh development of new technologies he
also wore this simultaneously that uh
the role of being
microsoft's chief liaison to major to
foreign governments when they were
entering foreign markets and to and and
indeed in washington uh as technology
policies were being considered there
he's a
he's recently gone into a kind of phased
retirement where he's going to be
where he's passed on that the large
management role that he had before and
now he's serving as senior adviser to
steve ballmer but here's a man who's
been close to bill gates first and then
steve ballmer as the
in over the last 20 years and has had a
lot to do with the shaping of one of
america's great companies
um
craig uh craig
has an astonishing grasp of emerging
technologies and that's what he's going
to talk about today
but uh and i'm sure he will want to
welcome questions in any area that he
talks about but frankly you can quiz him
on just about anything because any area
of technology that where technology
intersects
policy or changes in you know human life
he's he knows something about it it's
quite remarkable he's got great interest
in in uh
in the sort of use of
technology in
in biomedicine
and one of the signal contributions he
made to the president's uh commit
council of advisors
was in his leadership on our report on
healthcare i t where he essentially
conceptualized a whole new architecture
for keeping electronic health records
that was really a generation ahead of
where we are now and has provided very
important policy guidance as we think
about the future of healthcare i.t so
it's just a great pleasure to introduce
a great friend a great colleague and a
real leader of technology and business
strategy craig mundy
thank you very much
thank you rick it's very kind of you
yeah i think you're such an elaborate
introduction it's a pleasure to be at
yale we originally planned to do this a
few months ago and and the giant storm
forced us to cancel it at the last
minute
but i was committed to coming here and
and sort of
completing that that goal that we had of
talking here
these discussions on
college campuses are something that bill
gates and i for 20 years that i've known
him and worked with him we both have
really cherished these opportunities and
each year
that bill is at microsoft and in the
time since he's left you know i've sort
of
continued what was my own commitment to
spending about a week a year in the
united states visiting four sometimes
five
universities and giving a talk like this
but
i also spend time i have a round table
with students around table with the
faculty a roundtable with the
administration and with rick's help you
know we were able to arrange all those
today and it's been a fantastic
experience
part of the goal in doing these talks is
to not only share with you a little bit
of some of what we think is going to
happen that you might find interesting
particularly you know more and more as
technology is so pervasive in its
influence on our our lives and and our
work and and ultimately our societies
but it's also a chance for old guys like
me to get grounded you know uh in in
what's happening with young people and
what what uh sort of the fresh thinking
is that happens
largely in university campuses and
um and so you know it's a it's a two-way
transaction
today i'll spend about the first 45
minutes or so and give you some
ideas and demonstrations of some
technology that we're working on now
by and large almost everything i'll show
you is not a shipping product it's
mostly derived from work in our research
groups
that's not in the far future but in the
relatively near future
and so we'll keep our fingers crossed
that all of these prototype systems
actually work right
but i think you know
people like the people at yale would
certainly be pretty familiar with what
you can actually buy today and what you
can do with it at least that's my
operating assumption and so i think the
value add is to tell you what some of
the major things are from a trending
point of view and and what the
technology is that's going to help you
to realize some benefit from those
things
after that talk
we'll actually give away some of the
door prizes in case any of you have to
actually leave for another commitment
sort of on the hour but then i'm going
to stay
at least until 5 30 and have an open q a
and as rick said you know basically
there's no real rules you can you can
ask me anything about any topic and by
any have anything to offer that's
worthwhile
i'll i'll offer it
so it doesn't have to be confined to the
technology i talk about or microsoft or
anything else i'm happy to just have a
discussion with people
and then i guess we're going to have
free pizza after that so
for those who want to stay you get fed
too
they uh
so let me
start first and and talk about you know
how our own business is evolving
microsoft for many years has
been known primarily for windows and
office you could say although
if you really
look at it the company is is is a very
huge and diverse enterprise these days
you know we have about 93 000 people
about 45 000 engineers
and we build products across the entire
range from game consoles and and you
know high-tech gaming capabilities and
and content you know at the other end to
critical infrastructure components for
enterprises and governments and so i
think you know as a company it gives us
a perspective uh across everything that
that software and computing gets applied
to that that's pretty broad
uh also we're very i would argue one of
the world's most uh globalized
businesses i think
last count was like 201 countries that
the company actually operates in
and so you know we end up having to deal
with a lot of the things that are
imposed on companies
simply because of the diversity in in
the planet
and its people that we we ultimately
deal with
but there is a big change of foot in our
world over the last few years
many of these are things we've
anticipated we didn't always do a great
job in execution but it wasn't for lack
of understanding them
and that's the emergence of many many
devices
and all of them being computerized and
increasingly all of them getting
connected
in fact when bill gates and at the time
nathan mirvold hired me at microsoft it
was to do startups and the first
startups were to focus on how to think
about creating a system for
when when all these devices would become
computerized and so we've been working
on interactive television and game
consoles and watches and cars and
televisions literally since i went there
in 1992
uh and many of these things have now
come to market in our big businesses and
and some of them like interactive
television are still in the birthing
process
and it just shows that when you are
actually trying to change society's
infrastructure it takes a long time and
it takes a huge investment so merely
having the technology or the insight
about how it might be applied you know
still requires that you you think
carefully about
how these things ultimately are going to
get uh deployed and their many uh
interesting challenges as rick indicated
you know one of those challenges is that
many of these things are now in
regulated industries and while much of
the computer industry was born in an
environment where we didn't really think
much about regulation you know when you
start to
let this seep into virtually every form
of critical infrastructure and operating
environment that that the world has
you're inevitably going to face a lot
more regulation and that that affects
you know how you do the business and and
how you think about the products and it
was that that really originally uh
forced me to get involved in in all of
these diplomatic activities for the
company
the other thing that's really changed is
once everything got connected you know
we have evolved to where
there's almost no device or application
that we think about in isolation
either from the other devices in the
family of devices
or from the services that exist in the
backbone of the internet
and which essentially help to empower
these things
and yet they're all derived from
software uh and computing in one form or
another
and so you know we're going through
i think the sixth or seventh major
evolution in 38 years of the way we
think about our business
to not think about it so much as just
building software as a component that we
ship to other people
and that you buy on a perpetual use
license basis but rather that we people
want to buy these things more from us as
a as a
as a service something that that we
curate
and operate and that they can buy on a
usage-based model and so we're changing
a lot of how microsoft not only builds
its products but even how we think about
monetizing the software capabilities
that we have in the future
now one of the things that has obviously
been valuable
so far
has been
you know the graphical user interface
and almost everybody today thinks of
that as you know the innate or or basic
way in which they tend to operate
computers for a long time you operated
that with
pointing and clicking
and typing as the way to do it and
you know in the last
six seven years it's really exploded uh
in terms of
how people have sought to use touch and
ultimately other forms of human
sense-like capabilities as an
alternative way to drive that graphical
interface
but one of things i'll talk about
later in this in this talk
is a major focus at microsoft which has
been around the idea we call natural
user interface or nui to replace or or
supplement gui
and
natural in the sense that we want it to
emulate the way people
interact with other people we'd really
like the computer to be more like us
and we'd like to to find a situation
where through that
many more people can get much greater
utility from computing capability than
even that which has been achieved so far
you know if you look today there's
arguably maybe about two billion of the
seven billion people who really benefit
from computers and so there's more who
haven't yet had that you know benefit
then who have already enjoyed it and of
course it's this question of utilization
and the skills necessary to to use
computing that that in many ways along
with cost has been a limiter
but today you know the high volume of
these things has continued to drive the
cost down and in fact you can
go almost anywhere in the world in the
poorest places even and you know you'll
start to find
uh you know televisions and cell phones
and i think that you know there's no
reason to believe in the future that any
any person anywhere in the world who can
afford to buy a television or a cell
phone won't in the process in the
bargain be buying a computer system and
probably some type of
inherent connectivity
and with that you know we can really
think about how
computing then provides a much different
range of benefits for for all those
people
so uh touch has been an important change
you know this last version of windows
that we developed
windows 8 was one really the first time
where the company elevated touch-based
operation to sort of a first-class
citizen
status and you know we've uh brought
with oems and by ourselves these surface
products uh or
or windows eight based tablets to market
but we tend to believe that
over time we're going to see
all sizes of these
types of touch-based displays and that
they're going to find
many applications beyond that which we
historically have known
so i brought
this which is a new product from
microsoft which is
basically
i'll say the second largest tablet that
we sell
this one's 55 inches
and actually we currently sell one
that's 82 inches
and
uh in fact it is exactly the same
interface and and you know model of
operation that you have on a any
standard windows 8 tablet
and so
you know we're we're beginning to find
that when you take this model and
everybody has sort of focused so much on
mobility you know the cell phone and the
and the small tablet and while that's
important and powerful you know our
belief is that that largely through the
cost reductions that have been driven by
uh by television sales around the world
and ultimately even
uh the the emergence of projectors you
know like the one that drives that thing
to well over 100 inches of display
capability
these things have just continued to
plummet in price and so
even without assuming there's any
radical breakthroughs in technology we
find it completely plausible to believe
that you know you should think that
there will be a continuum of screen
sizes that will be ultimately touch and
gesture enabled and they'll range from
the very small probably as small as as
your watch perhaps you know up to the
very large
uh certainly which will be wall sized in
your office so inside microsoft you know
we we've actually started to deploy
these things you know not completely
broadly yet because we're still sort of
driving the cost out of them
but
those who have them including our ceo
find that having it in your office is
sort of transformational in the way that
you think about
doing meetings
and and how you interact with other
people you know in a university
environment uh certainly mike's was you
know you you sit and talk to a lot of
people trying to work on a problem it's
almost hard to do it without either
having a shared piece of paper or
frequently a chalkboard or a whiteboard
and there's just something powerful
about that ability to have this kind of
shared experience
and and we share that dream in a
powerful way and so by being able to put
these things
you know almost on any surface in the
future
you know you start to really think of
how a computer-mediated form of that
type of interaction becomes possible
the other thing that's happening is as
computers just get increasingly potent
we start to think about doing
applications in radically different ways
so i'm going to show you one of my sort
of personal favorites i i personally
sponsored the beginning of this work in
our sort of research and incubation area
i guess six or seven years ago
and it's now actually shipped as a
product called fresh paint
i don't know if any of you seen this but
you know if you uh look at i mean these
are you know things that you can now you
know buy
as little sort of like paint books for
like you buy for your kids let me just
first show you a little bit about what's
interesting about this you say oh hey
i've seen paint you know on my computer
but you've never really seen paint
probably like this because what this
thing actually is is a full-on physics
simulation
of painting
and so
the paper including its texture it has a
3d you know
model of the of the paper
uh the the different art mediums in this
case oil paint uh crayons and and
and pencil you know are actually all
modeled physically and the interaction
including of
the brushes
which are kind of indicated here
including the movement of the bristles
and the twisting of them and are all
done with physics simulations
and so in this case
you know
you know if i pick
any color
and
and any brush
and change you know the line width or
whatever it is
then you know what i've got is a ability
to
to
you know just paint with my finger or
with a brush
so you have a capacitive brush with the
real bristles and so more and more
there's this direct coupling between
sort of the virtual world and the
physical world and we're able to model
more and more of it
you say well that's nice dummy but
that's the wrong color for yale and we
don't make the a that way
and
so i say okay well you know what else
can we do help me since i'm not a very
good artist so
i can say well in here
somebody actually uh
helped me out and they took a
yale
logo and stuck it in here
and
you know it has
we'll say we're going to use this nice
fat brush because i'll be in a hurry
and
i'll show you one other thing this is
now this is simulating blue
oil paint
now when this thing was done
this started and assumed the outline was
actually in black
and oil paint
dries slowly
and so if i actually start the paint in
this thing
you'll see as i go across the lines
the blue paint mixes with the black
paint
because it wasn't dry
and
but if i say well i didn't really want
that i'm in a hurry the nice thing about
digital oil paint is i have this little
fan
and if i turn the fan on it dries
instantly
and so you know now i can paint and
no mixing of the blue and the black
and
this thing
in in the whole art in in the in the app
store for windows now
this is i think either the first or
second most popular application
and it really shows how when you give a
high quality tool to people
whether it's for the kids uh or it turns
out for people who are
professional artists who are trying to
figure out what is the future of the art
you know business so at yale i mean i
assume everybody's doing this already
but the uh you know how what's it going
to be when you want to preserve the
classical
concept of of oil based painting
and yet you want to
you know at least practice or learn or
be able to have these kind of digital
tools to do it
the really really wonderful part about
this is not only can you dry the paint
but if you make a mistake you can take
it off
and so if you think about this for
training kids
you know it's unbelievable because
there's no mess you know they they
defeat they develop a fearlessness
which of course is characteristic of
young people but it's really hard in art
you know because you make a mistake you
trash the whole thing you crumple it up
start over again here the rate at which
people can learn it turns out to be
quite accelerated because you know you
basically can correct errors
instantaneously
and so uh now you know we see all kinds
of these interesting things happening
where
uh for example we
we went and we wanted to create a thing
so we actually went to
to disney and said hey we want to
license old nemo
so that kids can paint nemo
and the thing that was remarkable they
said sure you don't have to do that and
then we showed this thing to their
animators
and the animators became so intrigued
with the whole thing that they ended up
creating a whole custom set of nemo
characters you know just specifically to
be able to be painted on this medium
and i just think we're going to see a
lot more of that very uh
very clever kind of interaction
in the future and you know who knows
where it'll end up
one of the more challenging things that
that we intend to do but it's not in
this product
uh but
uh we think we know how to do it now is
to do watercolors
uh including all the diffusion you know
and mixing that happens in in the papers
and so you know the
when you realize it i mean
the amount of computing that is going on
enable in order to be able to do this is
is really stunning uh and yet you know
it's going to be available to anybody on
a tablet for a couple of hundred bucks
and i think that that's going to be
quite remarkable
the next thing i want to talk a little
bit about is is big data you hear a lot
about it you know you can hear different
definitions of what it might mean you
know some people talk about the three
v's you know variety velocity and volume
as somehow indicators that your data is
big
in practical terms for us it really has
meant
you've got so much data
that you can't get a
sort of practical insight out of it in
any reasonable amount of time from
even the largest single machine
and
and so we've been building these really
super scale facilities in many cases
just to allow us to build and operate
these internet way internet scale
services
and what's happening more and more is
we're taking the architectures of those
machines
and adjusting them in ways that allow us
to not only ingest but then to process
uh these really staggering amounts of
data that are being created and the data
is flowing from all different sources
it's not
you know traditionally just the stuff
that that humans input directly or as a
byproduct of doing transactions
you know we're living in a sensor driven
world you know every cell phone you
carry around you know
you know maybe some of you have you know
i have the fitbit you know which
basically is a sensor pack in your
pocket that keeps track of your your
movement stair climbing you know
activity levels sleep uh you know so
more and more people are going to live
an instrumented life and that'll all get
you know plugged into this environment
there's all the classical you know big
data sets like things that that rick and
i worked on in the healthcare area for
president obama
and and as these come together our
ability to learn new things from them
represent
a real chance for breakthroughs in both
cost and efficacy of our health care
but there's two different ways that
we've thought about
how to get value out of this big data
and that we employ
initially inside microsoft for quite a
few years and increasingly you know will
be made available
as products for other people to use too
one of these is sort of to build on the
continuing uh trend in visualization
which depends on you know
using some type of graphical system
typically to couple human insight
you know into the problem
and you know that's a powerful tool and
and we think in the big data world
the ability to do that can be
made even better
the other one and i'll talk about that
more in a minute is machine learning
you know this is something that many of
us in computer science have pursued for
decades
but i think in the last few years we've
really made some breakthroughs in part
because of the scale of the machines
that we have
to operate on
and ironically in part because of the
volume of the data sets that we have to
operate on with those big machines
and we're actually starting to find that
many of the problems that we had in some
classes of machine learning were really
just the fact that we were sort of on
the right path a long time ago and gave
up on it too early simply because we
didn't have enough data to feed it and a
big enough machine to crunch it and when
you do you find out that you can
actually
solve some of these problems
so the next
thing i want to show you is
it came out of microsoft research
very recently
and it's called
internally sketch insight
and when you start to make the
assumption that you have tablets big and
small on all kinds of surfaces and you
want to use them for this type of
collaborative discussion or presentation
then you want the same kind of
naturalness that you get out of uh using
a chalkboard but again you know why
shouldn't you get more help from the
computer
so here this one uses you know this has
a pen so unlike just a normal touch
thing that many people use these systems
are quite different in that they also
support a very high resolution pen
and so you know it really is like having
uh you know a a pen or pencil that you
can write on these things with it's not
you know finger width drawing
and so this one we've loaded a few
different data sets in and the one i'm
going to demonstrate has some population
dynamics in terms of the global
population
now
so it's been taught a few gestures so
the first gesture uh
hopefully
is this one
and as soon as it recognizes it it sort
of strings it out and says okay what
that is he wants to have a graph and
make it a little easier i'll i'll
stretch this out for now
and move it over
and in this graph
i want to i want this to be population
versus
year
so if i start to write population here
it says oh okay well i only know if
couple things in this case one thing
that's in the data set and
you want population so yeah i don't have
to write the rest of it i'll put it in
there for you
right and then and same thing goes for
years so if i go down here and i start
to type year it recognizes that it says
okay yeah year i want year so then it
goes and extracts all the data and hooks
it up
and you can say wow gi uh i don't know
what do i like that date or not well
maybe i want to have
a a
bar graph so i can say you know make the
thing into a bar graph
so it'll redo that
i can say no i really think i'd rather
have a line graph so i'll just say you
know maybe i can make a line graph out
of it
and
i say i don't want all those individual
points what i want is
sum
so it sums them all up
and what i really want to know is not
just the the global population which
from 1960 to 2010 went from 3 billion to
7 billion
i want to know what it looks like by
continent
so yeah it knows about continent so it
splits it all out and puts it in
continent form
and
but then you know it do other
interesting things so i'll shrink this
back here a little bit
and
it says okay i also know how to make
other graphs so how about a pie chart
which is
by year
versus
population
and now it turns out that these all get
linked so these turn out to become
controls for the date on this side so
you know if i turn off the red one it
turns off 1960
and if i turn it on so now i've got it
suddenly made myself an interactive tool
you know that allows you to explore
different parts
now it knows how to make you know other
graphs too and so it has this inverted
gesture
knows how to
do geoplotting and maps
so now i've got a map and this map is
color coded to match that thing and it
also becomes a vehicle for controlling
this so if i say hey i really don't want
to look at all this data i you know i
only want to look at
eurasia
and north america so i turn all them off
and then i only get that data
and so suddenly you know you you're
doing all this interactively you've got
this huge data set you know behind you
uh and yet you come up with this very
very simple way to make the presentation
you can then record all these things you
can play them back and so the whole idea
of how you make a presentation how you
give a presentation how you collaborate
you know all will evolve over time
so
let me uh
go on and talk a little bit more about
the way that we think that this
collaborative type of
of work is going to go
we see
more and more of these business
intelligence type tools that we want to
build
and while this you know gave you some
assistance in trying to
um
control the sort of the drawing and the
linking of these these elements you know
we also wanted to try to build more
powerful tools that allowed you to sort
of see into super complex data in ways
that
would be really hard to do otherwise
so the next one i'm going to show you is
a thing called sandvance as a code name
inside microsoft research
and what this is is it's
pretty much
you know the entire u.s census data
and you know
turns out it's you know pretty much
easily stored in a single computer now
uh and
and it turns out if you just said well
you know there's okay there's the census
data it doesn't really make any sense
you know as as just a big blob
uh of all kinds of data so now you can
start to say well i want to assign
different you know like colors different
things so here's all the different
things that we extracted from the census
in this case what i'm going to do is i
want it i want to color code income
you know from low to high
green to red so now it goes through this
thing and it starts to color code each
of these census state things this is
census data at the i think the county
level
and you know you can at least now start
to see if you look carefully you know at
sort of what the general
income distribution is
but you know you can't really tell well
where is it
but the thing has different modes so if
i actually say what you know what i want
you to do now is go look for
latitude longitude data and and plot the
thing against latin long
so now
this isn't actually a map that got
filled in it's just the counties plotted
with their latitude and longitude and of
course what does it make it makes a
thing that looks like the united states
because it's all the counties of the
united states now
you know
you can sort of also see you know where
the population densities are and you can
see that that basically as you get you
know into the major cities in the you
know wherever they are in the country on
the coast in the middle you know that it
goes from red you know to to the middle
range and you get up here you know into
new york and new haven and a few other
places seattle san francisco los angeles
a few in the midwest chicago you start
to see a few sprinkled places get all
the way up to green they're where the
highest incomes are
and then you can do all kinds of
interesting things you can say
you know let's start to examine some of
these things so
instead of lat long let's
let's plot education levels
somewhere education on this axis
and
let's plot
income levels on this axis and they're
still color-coded
and
the let's see
education and i wanted unemployment was
what i wanted
that's different
so now what you see is
you know sort of education
in the county as in terms of average
amount of education
versus the unemployment rates and so you
begin to ask interesting questions
so now you can ask questions by just
graphically saying i'm going to put a
box around these three because they're
sort of outliers in terms of how high
the unemployment is and very low and i
can say well who are those
and
it turns out that those three things are
apache county in arizona
apache county in arizona different one
and
coconino county in arizona so basically
three of the indian reservations
in the united states happen to have the
lowest average income i mean education
and the highest average unemployment
in the whole country you know there's uh
other you can go at the other end of the
spectrum and basically pick this one
and say okay what's that guy and you'll
all be having to know that's stanford
and so it's interesting is in stanford
county
they have a lot of education but
uh
their unemployment level is pretty low
but they also don't have a green dot for
income so
yeah
in any case you know there's things that
you could discover in this data
by just crawling around in it and
organizing it and sorting it in these
ways that that you might never know you
know if i if i went back and looked at
you know that particular data in the
geographic you know sure enough it shows
up over here at stanford
now another thing that we think is
happening a lot and if you were here
before we started and watched one of the
videos
the
we increasingly think that many of the
applications of these devices whether
they're tablets or phones or
or these wall size or conventional
computers is no longer going to be sort
of consumed one device at a time
you know we've already started to ship
this technology called smart glass where
your phone or your or your uh tablets
become sort of an in your lap
control mechanism for your entertainment
experience you can play games that way
you can browse the internet on your
television and the keyboard and
you know mouse manipulation on your tv
screen are just done through the device
that's in your hand
but increasingly we expect that the same
thing will be done in
in the business environment so if you're
collaborating with somebody and you're
looking at all this data then it it
turns out that you know
a colleague might be sitting at you know
having a tablet in their hand in your
office or they could be sitting across
the country and they could be looking at
either the same data or they can be
looking at a slightly different one so
you know for on this one let's just say
i'm interested in knowing where
you know the sort of the middle income
people are
that are in median age
and so you know i can select that by
just in this different graph which was
plotting median age against income i
highlight a part of that
and you know
on on my screen in my office what lights
up is the same yellow dots but in the
configuration i'm looking at you can say
well you know it turns out that the
people who make reasonably high incomes
and are fairly young you know seem to be
clustered
around the big cities which of course
you'd expect
but
your ability to explore in this way and
to do it collaboratively in real time is
increasingly going to happen more and
more
uh the down the video that we showed
during the walk-in part for example of
the the choir at ted which was part
skype and part and pre you know physical
presence
i think all of these things are just
examples that more and more the
geographic barriers are just going to
disappear
and whether you're physically in the
same place or in different places that
the idea of of real-time collaboration
communication even entertainment you
know will increasingly come not to be
commonplace
i mentioned earlier that
you know if i think of these things as
sort of the analytical tools based on
visualization and where i'm trying to
get the human intellect coupled into the
problem as directly as i can you know
that's one way to do it but there are a
lot of things buried in the data where
in fact the people don't have an idea
you know we'd like to have an answer but
we don't really know
and that's where machine learning
really is going to be a powerful tool
and today a lot of that is based on
supervised learning where it takes you
know some sort of high priests to to
manipulate the machine learning
capability but increasingly we're
we're being able to to to improve that
and the holy grail being a lot of
ultimately unsupervised learning
but
even along the way
making tool kits that allow people to
have this type of high scale machine
learning facility applied to these huge
data sets many huge data sets
is getting better and better
so let me show you
you know one
other way that we're starting to think
about you know
coupling together this idea of
of searching and learning
uh in order to create other ways to make
discoveries and do navigation
so uh what we have again is an another
prototype
and what this thing is is called doc map
and
if you look at these you know topics you
should find all of them
familiar to somebody here what we
ingested was
you know some large number of years
worth of all the research papers
published by the computer science
department at yale
and
and what this system does is it actually
reads all the papers
and it
it categorizes them
it it tries to sort of understand them
and cluster them
around words and based on the size of
the words you get some sense of the
frequency with which that topic appeared
in this whole space
and for any word that's selected
it basically gives you a
a
list so think of this as a
like a search engine
but this search engine figures out what
the interesting words are you want to
search on
and then it it shows you all the words
that are adjacent to those words so you
start to find you you discover
topical relationships that you you know
might have never known about
so this this works you know where you
can actually uh
scan in do things
maybe
there it is it just takes a little time
uh and if i if i pick one of these uh
words and
and
let's just
well we picked a couple so i wouldn't
have to type too much so
i'll pick vision
and put it in and this thing will go
grind around and it'll find everything
that had vision in it and and there's a
few clusters of them so here's one
around visualization one around shape
uh other things and if i basically take
these things and and scroll into them
you know i i could look up
you know it'll it'll start to add more
and more
uh
granular detail
and you know i can pick any one of these
capabilities uh you know let's just say
transformational
and it goes out and it finds the papers
that were in that cluster and it gives
me a list of them
so
you know here for example is uh
is one fast lance stack a notion of
radon transform for data in a cartesian
grid which is rapidly computable i was
really exact geometrically faithful
invertible that's quite a title
uh but if i actually
touch this it says okay you want me to
get you the paper and i say yeah just
save it for me
and
it does it
so now i basically discovered a paper
that i didn't know existed in a field
that i may have an interest in
uh and i'm able to to
to go get it
now
as i said we really expect these
devices to come in many different
shapes and sizes and flavors and you
know this one uh which was built by the
guys who do this stuff
is special in that it it also has
things that make it change its shape
but what it
what it does increasingly you know you
may not buy one that'll actually either
stand up or lay down by itself although
you clearly can do that uh
i think people will find that they'll
replace their white boards with these
things and increasingly they'll replace
their desk with these things
and what you want is an environment
where this whole idea of how you think
about you know operating
once again to be very natural that the
same things that you
already know how to do with your hands
and a pen
you want them to apply in exactly the
same way to the manipulation or review
of documents
in this environment
so you know if i take this thing and
drag it out here
from where it was saved and if i blow it
up
sure enough there's that
paper
and
you know i can read it
you know
just flick through it as i was you know
turn the pages of a book you know i
could you know if i wanted to have a
different you know document
let's just take take another one and
pull it out over here
and
i can move this guy around put him up
there
make it bigger
active vision system for a social robot
you know if i
let's just say i'll
pick
yellow to highlight this now i i got my
pen and of course if you think about how
you would normally work
what people don't really realize unless
you study it is if i give you a piece of
paper and i ask you to write something
the first thing let's say your right
hand the first thing you do is you put
your left hand down on the paper and
then you think you start to write
someday go try to write without using
your left hand
all right you'll find it incredibly
difficult
that
people when they write are almost
continuously changing the relationship
of the paper to themselves and to the
thing that they're writing in in order
to facilitate it so writing is really a
two-hand thing for most people not a
one-hand thing of course computers in
the past haven't really facilitated that
because if you had a touch interface it
got confused all right well was he
touching or writing
so in this system it actually can
distinguish completely separately the
touch of your hand from the touch of the
pen
and
in addition it's not just one touch it's
arbitrary touch
and
so it turns out now the process of if i
want to review this this uh this
document
the
my you know i can turn the pages and i
say well it's really kind of hard to
annotate it that way but if i actually
just put my hand down this paper works
just like real paper so i can write with
two hands i could annotate this you know
i could i could flip it up i can go to
the next page
uh you know i can make the whole thing
bigger i can make the whole thing
smaller
and all of the things that you would
naturally do by just you know the
movement of your your your left hand to
control the
ratio the relationship of the paper to
your pen and to your eye all that
happens completely naturally so much
like the fresh paint was an attempt to
simulate the physics of painting
more and more we're trying to you know
emulate the physics of dealing with pen
and paper
you know it's been around a while you
know for good reason
and the question is just because you can
say everything should be on a screen
doesn't mean you should give up you know
the long developed
capabilities and benefits that people
have from operating
in this environment you know you can do
other interesting things you know here i
can pull in a map
you know i can basically make the map
big
you know with one hand i can you know
twist it around like i would if i was
let's say i'm looking here for new haven
so i just kind of zoom in okay here
comes new haven
and i can just keep moving it around
with one hand until i find it
and say okay here we are you know yale
university
and
so i mean you know the ability to take
this map in real time over the internet
suck it up manipulate it twist it around
annotate on it clip parts out of it send
it to other people it's basically better
than better than paper
because i haven't given up almost
anything
that was a problem in
the ability to manipulate the thing but
i gained the ability to pan and zoom to
rotate it you know to clip things out of
it and do things that are just
impossible with paper so i think that
you know more and more
these are examples of what we call
natural user interfaces
it's not simply the idea can we emulate
speech and vision and and you know
haptic kind of things it's can you then
use those to build new models
of interaction for applications that
make it just completely natural for
people to use these computer systems so
we're very
excited about that and while the
classical graphical interface isn't
going to disappear
i think it's we're kind of in a stage
now
which has you know i'll say frequently
occurred when technology shifts happen
you know people remind me
i'm old but i'm not quite this old
that when the
motion picture camera was invented
the first thing they did with it was
they filmed plays
and it was actually only years later
that they realized that you know that
they didn't have to film the whole play
at once
they could actually film chunks of it
and then
splice the films together and so what we
know today is the major motion picture
wasn't at all what anybody had in mind
when they created the movie camera
and and i think we're kind of in that
stage now in this transition between
graphical interfaces you know and the
movement to natural interaction that
when you get to this point you really
want to stand back and ask yourself the
question
you know
how do i just get the computer to help
me more i always tell people like one of
my goals for the work at microsoft is
i say okay how should a farmer in rural
india you know be able to use this
machine learning you know capability you
know he should be able to pick up his
phone
and
and say
what day should i fertilize
and the thing comes back and says
thursday
all right
and so i mean in essence he asked a
question that is exactly what he would
have asked to a human colleague that he
who
knew the context was an expert in the
domain you know and knew everything
about you know what the guy was already
doing
and
that's the power of this big data
machine learning combination
is it allows us to essentially
continually learn about context
you know for those of you that have
people that work with you whether
they're assistants you know personal
assistants
people working your lab with you
you realize
those people get more valuable to you
the longer you work with them
for the most part and and the reason is
they have context
and
right now your computers by and large
are not getting more valuable the longer
you work with them because it isn't
essentially
aggregating the context that it has
but with computers so intimately
involved in you know our work our play
you know uh you know our shopping
virtually everything that we do
the amount of context that the system is
capable of of inhaling and and managing
is really stunning
that brings with it a whole set of new
challenges both on the policy uh and
regulatory front as well as the
technology front for example in in the
privacy space uh when rick and i worked
on the health it reported actually
one part was the invention of the
mechanism that would solve the problem
of combining the data and the happy
thing was that it also turned out to be
a mechanism that gave you a way to have
the technology manage the usage-based
access to the data hence an attempt to
solve the privacy problem
and
i think you know this is one of the
great challenges for the computer
science and computer business community
these days is to try to figure out how
do you design these systems such that
the value of the big data isn't forced
to be lost simply because people are
paranoid about certain bad things could
happen
many more good things can happen we just
have to be sure that we can reel in the
bad ones exposed facto and i think it's
completely clear that we have the
technical means to do that it's just
that people haven't been
sort of forced or or
or made
incentivized to go build those things
yet but i think that'll come
so
let me move on you know beyond this type
of i'll say analytics and discovery
where the human is driving a little bit
more to the kind of things that we're
doing where the machine is driving uh
the discovery process
and
you know if you look at this
slide it's just six examples i selected
where microsoft inside the company for
as long as
i go as far back as at least eight years
like i can remember
has been using machine learning in order
to build
sort of surprising capabilities into
products
speech recognition
you know in phones and other devices for
quite a long time
true skill many people in the room
probably have at some point played an
xbox game and if you play multi-party
versions
over the network and you go to the game
lobby you know to just to find somebody
to play with
it turns out one of the challenges we
discovered very early on is when you
have so many people if you use just
random assignment of players you get a
very un appetizing experience for both
for all the people
because the odds that you have people
that are you know reasonably well
matched
is not that high uh because you know the
the quality of your gameplay can vary in
so many dimensions that there's no
simple metric you know that says hey you
know is this guy a good match for that
guy
and so we started to use machine
learning to figure out
out of this huge uh
you know multi-dimensional space which
things produced satisfying competition
you know otherwise it's sort of like
putting a pro against an amateur the
amateur says why do i even try and the
pro says why am i wasting my time
playing this idiot and you know and you
don't want that so you really want all
these competitions to be pretty much
even up and that that system does that
the whole search and ad business is all
built on machine learning you know
knowing what ad to deliver when to
deliver it how does how to scan the web
what to you know keep and what not to
keep uh you know is a machine learning
problem
one of the things that we actually just
shipped that's been a dream for many of
us for a long time is the intelligent
inbox
in office 365 we've just started to turn
on this capability
it observes how you handle all your mail
you know for several thousand pieces of
mail and and based on what it learns it
begins to automatically uh
manage your inbox for you it clusters
things together it moves things that it
thinks you would assume a higher
priority up
and it even gets to the point where it
can start to make recommended
disposition of those documents like
it'll you know you sit down and the
thing sees you and says okay you know i
looked at your mail and all these i
think you're going to delete should i
all right
and you just say yes and they'll go away
and
these it says you know these i know
you're going to respond to
and i i've drafted some you know basic
responses for you uh you want to send
them and so more and more you know the
computer just starts to say when it can
pattern match and say i i know that this
person's important and this one less you
know it starts to help you figure that
out the whole concept of gesture
recognition in connect was all based on
machine learning
and
in bing maps traffic prediction you know
if you go and ask for a route it says do
you want to know that you know now what
the traffic is
telling people here's the route
only based on the traffic that we
currently have is not all that
interesting now what's a lot more
interesting is to predict
you know over the time it takes them to
drive the route what will the traffic be
at those points
so by basically taking on all the
historical factors and all the exogenous
things like weather and ball games and
and everything else and then monitoring
accident reports the thing can actually
figure out a forecast of you know what
what congestion will be like at every
point in the route before you drive it
and then it'll adjust the route
dynamically
one of the great things that's been holy
grail for us at microsoft and many
people in the in the computer science
research community for years has been
the quest to do real-time
speech-to-speech
translation
and
in microsoft one of the ways that we try
to aggregate our research results
into solving larger scale sort of
composite real world problems is to give
ourselves these kind of objectives and
so
about two years ago rick rashid who's
shown in the next slide i think it comes
up is uh he's the guy who found it and
actually runs microsoft research day by
day
he said hey you know
by the end of 2012 i want to go to china
give a speech and and i want to be able
to
speak in
my normal voice in english
and i
i want the
loudspeaker system to
come you know to project
chinese
in essentially real time
in my own voice
and uh
so
we actually did that uh we think that's
sort of a real milestone achievement in
the field and it was all based on some
real breakthroughs in the last few years
in what's called deep neural networks
and the use of these very high scale
machines and very large data sets
to be able to train
machines
to be able to do this so i'm going to
show you a one-minute clip that was from
that speech in china last fall
but you get an idea what what you'll see
happening and i'll explain it now so you
can watch it is he talks it translates
his speech
into
english text
it converts the english text to chinese
text
it does
a text-to-speech synthesis in
chinese
all right
and then it plays that through a vocoder
model that we developed from his voice
so it's actually his vocal tract that so
just like fresh paint was a simulation a
painting this is a simulation of his the
physics of his vocal tract you know and
we use that so that the things it's a
language he doesn't speak but it's his
voice
in another language
so we'll play that for one minute i'm
speaking in english
and hopefully you'll hear me speak in
chinese in my own voice
again the results are not perfect
there are in fact quite a few errors
there's much work to be done in this
area
but this technology is very promising
you'll enjoy the t-shirts
and we hope in a few years that we'll be
able to break down the language barriers
between people
so what do you think
so you know this turns out to be again
important if you go back to the walk-in
video of the ted choir you know there it
was music and you didn't have a language
problem
uh and you had people from all over the
world who could who could collaborate
with each other but by and large
language is a problem and will obviously
remain so for a long period of time if
you want to have a sort of global
communication and collaboration
particularly in real time
and so
the idea that uh and i'm going to ask
ethan to come up and and we'll kind of
move into this next demo a little bit um
to think about what it's like
whether you're sitting at a desk like
this where he is or i am and there's
just a
tablet sitting here running skype it's
on a desk that looks like it has a desk
lamp this is a very special desk lamps
and that they are both they both project
and see at the same time
they don't just light
and
yeah
we'll show you just a second and but if
you think about it you know when i sit
down here
today you know he's and i both speak
english
and
you know i could ask him for some help
or he could ask me for some help but
again we wanted the thing to be very
natural so this is a research thing
called the lumashare
and what it does is it it basically
brings the idea of
you know natural drawing reading writing
examination of objects
at a distance
you know to an environment where people
don't have to know anything to be able
to do that so you're looking at
essentially what i'm seeing so he's
writing in real time with a regular pen
it shows up on paper on his side and it
shows up projected on my side
and and so you know we both appear to
see exactly the same thing i'll
uh you know i'll just use green and i'll
circle this and you know in real time he
would see that on the other side
the
we can give this to
children that literally aged three years
old and they sit down and they use it
immediately and the idea that that the
person they're collaborating with is
somewhere else they see them on the
screen they draw works you know like
what's the problem and uh
and but you know you can take things and
say hey you know how about helping with
my my math
you know so you know he can take a
uh you know his his triangle and he can
draw something there
you know he can put another line there
and i say look
all right well you know i could i can
finish this drawing and
you know i could be getting some help
you know
you could think of doing this you know
rick and i talk a lot about moocs you
know what's their impact on education at
every level and around the world but you
know if you have this
as a vehicle where you're taking online
courses and you've got social
interaction and you can do this kind of
you know help help me figure this out
you know i can say hey this looks like
it's 90 degrees you know this one who
knows you know
i don't know what this this thing is but
he could measure it for me so 39 degrees
so i can say all right well what do you
think this one is
and he can explain to me that you know
they have to add up to 180 and it all
works
and
and so there's a lot of interesting
stuff now these discussions these
interactions are all being recorded in
the cloud
so to some extent
yeah close enough
uh
but you know now if i take this paper
and throw it away you know you can see i
only had half of the conversation and he
had half of the conversation
uh and what we really
want to do is be able to
each ultimately walk away thinking we
had the whole conversation
so we'll do like one more that shows how
this might work so we
because we're more and more focused on
machine vision another big use of
machine learning you know here's a set
of objects and as the as the system
begins to
recognize these objects you can do more
interesting things so here
you know
what this is it's a gadgeteer board it's
just it's it's a thing where people who
want to prototype small electronic
gadgets they buy these things and so he
you know may have said to me hey look
i've got this thing i have no idea
really how to hook it up and i say yeah
well i've played with this and i can
tell you that you know these
these five things here are all where you
plug in the usb connectors and you know
this set of things down here is where
you plug in the leds
and you know this little button right
here is the reset button
and
you can say okay thanks that's really
useful
but he says now i've got to go away and
use it so if i walk away and crumple
this thing up
and he walks away
you know the next time he comes and sits
down at a system the thing basically can
look at the physical object
you know hopefully we'll recognize that
it's seen it before
and basically brings back you know the
annotations and it'll register them no
matter where he puts it and you know how
he moves it around
and so basically it is as if he had the
whole conversation even though part of
it was virtual and part of it was
physical
thanks ethan thanks and
so
so this is one of the really popular
things it turns out you can take this
lamp and turn it up and shine it on the
wall same thing works
okay
so you know whether you want to do white
boards or desktops
you know we think that ultimately
the cost of this shouldn't be
substantially more than the cost of a
desk lamp
uh
and because you know if you look at how
small we can make cameras and you know
how cheap led lighting is and you know
these little projectors are now that's
all we assemble this out of and then a
bunch of clever software algorithms and
interfacing technology because it turns
out you know what you have to do is
interleave the frames so you one frame
you project and then you blank and then
you look all right and by interleaving
these things at a high rate it appears
that you're doing both at the same time
even though it's in a high ambient light
kind of environment
so
you know this is uh
this is the way that we're making
computers
you know more like us
and with it i think you know we're we're
making these things much more powerful
much more available
to people and and i think easier to use
and get real benefit from
so let me just close by showing you just
a short video that it just came from uh
every year microsoft research holds a
thing we call tech fest and it's sort of
our internal market for ideas that we
generate in research because there's
about you know i think not only a
thousand people in the core research
group
and about
35 or 40 000 people in the engineering
groups that make make products and you
know the real question is always when
you do basic science how do you get it
tech transferred uh you know in an
efficient way and it's a challenge even
in one company you know it's a challenge
and so we created tech fest a few years
ago which is like a a trade fair that we
put and all the people from our labs
in the 10 places around the world
come and we set this big thing up for
three days and they come and they go
and they just walk around and see all
these things so
some of the a lot of the talk that i
gave you today were things i selected
now it turns out each year we down
select about 200 of the best things
that come out of research and what i
showed you today was about four or five
and so i'm just going to show you a
video that's just like a
you know eye candy that that just
you know you know flashes by and you'll
see the the incredible range of things
that is ongoing and you know i offer
that to you
to help you understand
you know so many people i think get
jaded they say oh computers i understand
it all how's it going to change you know
i mean we've seen everything and you
know our view is you haven't seen
anything yet
uh you know the the rate at which this
stuff is changing is is very high and
you know the amount of benefit that
society will get from it is is amazing
so let's close with the last video
this one i showed you here
so just another dozen or two of the
things that are going on uh it's uh
incredible uh privilege to be able to be
affiliated with this group and this
company uh and you know i hope you get a
little appreciation for the range of
things that we do
so uh before we go into the q a session
and because i know some people can't
stay for the whole time we're going to
give away the door prizes
and so if you get your little tickets
out
i'm going to pull out these things and
this is erica she she is the person you
want to see to claim your gift
so the first two gifts
are new handy-dandy windows phone 8
maybe two of them
so the first
one is and i'll just say the last three
digits ends in three one five
three one five you have to be present to
win
no no three one five
okay
one down and pick another one
763.
okay
all right
so see this lady afterward the phone
all right second phone 8 25.
okay there's the second phone all right
okay we're going up we're going up scale
here now
now we're giving away three xbox with
connect
okay 191.
191 there it is over here
all right
next one
764.
so okay back in the corner there
and the third
xbox
925
oh oh close no cigar
925 right oh back there okay that's
great
okay and the last are three surface rts
okay so 153
153
okay there's one that's a lucky row over
there i'll have to sort these better
7 49
i think there's something going on here
three in a row over there
okay
nine zero seven
okay back over there that that's two
that's all three of them okay great
all right
enjoy them
okay so if you have to leave or you're
welcome to go don't
go bad and if you want to stay
we'll do q a for another uh
20 minutes or so
huh
rick says i should tell you that it's
pepe's pizza that's being served at the
end so
i guess that's significant
yeah okay
so
okay so there's two microphones in the
aisles up here and if you want to have a
question line up there and we'll
pipeline between the two of them
so
i think this lady wants to be first
so
let's go ahead and start
okay hi thank you so much for the
presentation and thank you for the demos
i really appreciate the demos um i
actually have a question about the very
first devil you showed us i was
wondering um in addition to
the physics engine for rendering the
graphics for painting um are you going
to
have you thought about incorporating
haptic feedback into the stylus or the
pens or the paint brushes so that when
the painter paints on the surface though
have some sort of haptic feedback on uh
on the pen
so like when they can feel uh friction
or viscous drag or even the bumps on the
surface yeah yeah i don't really know
myself whether the team has
actively contemplated that or not of
course we have a huge amount of
experience on the gaming side with
haptic feedback so i i think you know
technologically it's possible it's hard
to i think not distort the
you know the feel i mean we have a bunch
of things in research
where i've actually used them not with
the fresh paint application where
you know we're providing haptic feedback
like where you can take a stylus or
something and move it you know or you
can like you push it and see a virtual
object and hit it you know you feel that
you run into it but to do it you know
you got a pantograph type of mechanism
you know with actuators that are you
know there to create that kind of
three-dimensional force and it's it's
hard for this kind of freehand thing
to to keep yourself attached and i think
not disturb that relationship but you
know i'm i'm sure somebody will come up
with some clever way you know to figure
that out okay great thank you
hi um thank you so much for coming here
love the presentation
my name is ayusha i'm a cs major here
and i see a bunch of other cs people
here too and what i really want to know
is how do you get a job at microsoft
research
um
well by and large
the the research people primarily i i
would say to the
you know 90 odd percent level you know
we only hire people who have phds
in the fields of interest primarily
computer science but but it's it's quite
broad now we're
we've actually built a group doing
economics uh you know we have a group
that is
focused a lot in social
uh you know
behavioral science and that kind of
thing
and
but you know
send your resume to those guys i mean
that
i mean i'll tell you it is selective and
a lot of people who end up there at one
point or another have have passed
through microsoft research either as an
intern a post doc you know or or some
other uh capacity you know in their on
their way to ultimately getting in there
um you know we don't grow the thing very
quickly and and we have a very low
turnover so you know it's
there's some opportunity every year but
it's not a huge number today we have
about 900 phds
doing the basic science
thank you
when i saw the
demos of some of your products i
couldn't help but notice that
even the high performance data
visualization ones were being run out of
a web browser i was wondering uh what
sort of framework you were using to do
that
to be honest i don't know what they
probably did i mean look most of the
stuff we're doing now i mean
you were talking earlier today you know
we do stuff with silverlight there's a
huge effort on html5 based
uh you know capabilities and i i don't
know what
you know the research guys used for
these particular demos
i've just never tried to go look at it
thank you
hi
so
now that computers are being much
integrated into our lives in a greater
integration level to basically every
aspect of our lives i was wondering what
level of computer science education
should be given as either a core
component of
of a college education or even lower
level than college education
well one i think it should start a lot
earlier than college
uh i actually was talking at dinner last
night to rick's wife jane and
we actually were having this
conversation because
i was
basically saying that you know my view
was that
that this idea this idea of what we call
computational thinking
is it's not computer science it's not
programming but it's basically
understanding you know how you think
about problem solving using
computational methods
is something that a woman at microsoft
research now named jeanette wing has
been advocating when she was at the
national science foundation and i do
think that from an early age we need to
start to basically get people uh
exposed at least in the abstract to
computational thinking
and and if you understand that then it's
easier to sort of branch out based on
how aggressive you want to be in terms
of either understanding implementation
learning programming but more and more
the number of things you can do without
writing a line of code is unbelievable
one thing
maybe some of you already seen it it's
it's in the current shipping version of
excel
you know the spreadsheets were fantastic
you know because they gave people who
didn't have to write a line of code a
direct ability to translate what they
wanted to do in that sort of spreadsheet
computational model you know and using
only things they understood like writing
math formulas you know the ability to
make very powerful analyses
but there are a lot of things that we do
particularly in this big data world
where
you can't express those things in any
check the box you know script or or menu
like thing
so what we just shipped in
in the new version of excel is a feature
called flash fill
and what flash fill does is it actually
does real-time program synthesis
so you teach it what you want it to do
to data by showing a few examples of the
transformations and each time you give
it an example it re-synthesizes a
program that will do that to all your
data
and
and and and it runs it in real time and
then you look at it and if there's
something wrong you take the one that
wasn't right you changed that example
re-synthesized it again and and
in most cases you can write a program
without knowing you're writing a program
by just showing it teaching it what you
wanted it to do to the data and i think
that more and more for the vast majority
of people
they
won't
they will get very satisfying results
from their computer without
ever having the idea that they had to
write a program
and i think that that's why i think in
terms of this basic education it's going
to be more important to teach people
computational thinking than it is any
particular computational method
that we use today
well
just a very quick statement i would
think those of us in computer science
hope that what we're teaching is the
computational thinking and the
programming language is just an added
bonus
doesn't seem to be true
to be completely candid
just you know
from at least from my vantage point and
jeanette you know who spent a lot of
time thinking about this stuff
you know i don't i don't think we're
getting there even in the computer
science departments
and we're certainly not doing it for
young kids
and you know i think that we have to
think that reading writing and
arithmetic you know you need to have the
the fourth one you know which is sort of
computational thinking has to be in
there somehow
for people to be able to be functional
in this world of the future
thank you
hi so um thank you very much for the
talk again
my question was uh regarding
synchronization and identity
management so in the future i see power
users maybe
having a microsoft surface tablet
wearing google glasses and listening to
music on their iphones at the same time
so how does microsoft have any plans to
work towards sort of synchronizing all
of these technologies and allowing
people to maintain
one identity
uh
well i mean you know we
we produce these identity systems and we
let all the third party application
people use them
so in a sense
we're not stopping
google or anybody else from deciding to
allow that identity to be used or
federated with their own identity
right now i think that each of these
companies tends to think hey you know
i've got my community and if i can keep
them corralled under this identity
then you know they like that better and
you know microsoft comes you could say
more from a platform orientation
historically where we
kind of give people these tools and let
them write you know anybody could write
any app for windows you know anybody can
do write any you know macro for excel or
macro for office and so
i think in these in the case of identity
we are already very active in this idea
of having a federate identity because we
know that people can't just have one
so for example we know everybody has got
to have at least
you know also called a personal identity
a government-issued identity a
uh
probably an an institutional identity
you know and
so just let's just let's just say even
if they're willing to accept microsoft
account as a personal identity
if they go to work they probably get a
work identity and when they were born
the government gave them an identity
and
you know somehow they're all going to
have to get federated so we're focused a
lot more on
producing the mechanism for federation
and then it'll be up to the market to
decide or demand you know when these
things
app by app essentially get federated
thank you
all right it was very impressive to talk
i was really enjoyed it my my question
was about the competition between
microsoft and apple
so i think i remember when i was in high
school i think was way before iphone
that i saw this
fantastic video that as the video show
me showed us today about you know i
think the video was about surface
computing i don't know whether you
probably know that project and then you
know and then after that you know 2007
steve jobs launched iphone and then you
know ipad and
so what happened what slowed microsoft
down you know in the competition between
you know apple
and
i think the second part of the question
is you show us the this marvelous app
you know when you can you know
use oil painting or something but
there's already this app there are
actually a bunch of apps that are
fascinating that digital illustrators
are using in app store like you know
procreate or the app called paper that i
use every day in an app store that does
fantastic job about you know water
coloring and actually they they have you
know stylus with you know
whatever bluetooth and can have you know
palm rejection so you actually can't
tell whether you are touching the paper
or you actually are writing so
you know all the things that you said
today was very impressive but i think
you know there's something that i was
thinking yeah microsoft is doing great
but
you know how are they going to compete
with apple since they're sort of you
know half a step ahead so that's my
question
yeah
i mean that
my view of this is that
it's frustrating for me but
you know microsoft shipped
music players before the ipod touch
you know devices before the touch
uh
had a 30 share in smartphones before
there was an iphone and have shipped
you know tablet computers for 13 years
i'd say our problem wasn't technology
our problem was marketing
you know we basically as a company made
a set of choices during that period of
time for a variety of reasons
that ended up with us not making the
kind of investment that was necessary to
sustain those leadership positions or to
capitalize on them and once you see them
you know then recovering them is
is more difficult
and
you know you can say the good news and
bad news at least microsoft has the
technological capacity and financial
capacity you know to take these things
that you know maybe are strategic and
that we didn't
follow through on and work to recover
our positions
the thing i'll point out
i mean
if i go back
five or six years
and i give you this i'll give you this
quiz okay six years ago
who were going to be the kings of
smartphones i would probably answer
nokia words
nokia motorola and rim
maybe okay
so they all basically
are you know dead or dying
and the reason is they weren't software
companies
all right
and
their ability to basically
keep in a leadership position
when the thing was no longer about
making
phone calls but where phone calls are
just an app on a computer that's in your
hand
was an inversion of their skill set
we at least you know don't have
that problem microsoft you know i think
as a demonstrator can be able to do
either the hardware if we have to or the
software
and and we've you know learned some of
our lessons you know
for our failures we paid a big price for
some of that that problem
and so i i think that
you know
we probably hopefully won't make the
same set of mistakes twice at this
juncture
and i'll also point out that if i just
went back i'll say
two or so years ago
and said
you know
well do you guys think apple is
unstoppable in phones are they just
gonna you know rule the planet on phones
most people would say oh i guess so
and right now their share is only 67
percent or 65 percent of samsung's share
and
so
it turns out all of the consumers are
incredibly fickle
all right
and as a result you know all they care
about particularly groups like this one
is you know the cool factor
and
and they can afford it
and so
you know
i don't think apple has any lock on this
stuff at all
and you know
they've done a great job doing what they
did
we let them do it
all right
and you know my view is had we been on
top of our game on the sort of marketing
side
at the time where we had put these
things out
you know you'd be sitting around asking
you know can anybody stop microsoft in
this category
so you know it just shows that you know
in business
all the elements of execution are
important and you know we can have the
big research group we can have all the
products we can even ship them earlier
than other people but if you don't
basically at the weight of the company
behind it when you're in these new
categories it doesn't guarantee you any
sustained success
and frankly even having some sustained
success doesn't guarantee it you know if
somebody comes along with the next cool
thing
so
you know the
you know i guess you know we'll wait and
see what happens
you know it was kind of
it's kind of funny i mean when we
shipped the surface
you know apple kept saying
you know in a joking way you know why
would anybody want one of these things
you know that it seems to be this this
hybrid
you know and we said well why would
anybody think they had to carry two
devices
you know so the marketplace will
ultimately tell us you know who was
right and who was wrong but i can tell
you that i go to a lot of places today
where people are walking around with
ipads and
macs
and saying you know why can't i like
rick was asking he says well you know i
really want office on the ipad but i
have to carry my mac
okay
and
you know i just think that
that that people ultimately resonate
with the stuff that helps them get their
jobs done
and when you have breakthroughs in some
of these areas the momentum shift is
very very quickly
you know and i think you know people you
even see that reflect a little bit in
how the market values apple you know
down from 700 to 400 and change you know
that's a reflection of something i mean
we have the same problem for 10 years
we've been flat because people keep
wanting to declare that we're going to
die
okay we're the third most valuable
company in the country all right
you know we make more money than these
other guys do in profit and so you know
the market is a weird weird animal but
you know i think we're doing some
interesting stuff and
we'll see how the market reacts thank
you so much and good luck with the next
down here thanks
hi so firstly i also just wanted to say
thank you and i was really impressed
with especially the visualization demos
um i have like three questions
okay
um so the first was related to what the
previous guy just asked um
while you were demonstrating the
painting app like the first thing that
popped into my mind was i've seen this
before like seven years ago because um i
do like digital arts
so i've seen a lot of this so
um i guess my question for that is
um there's definitely going to be a lot
of you've actually seen something seven
years ago that actually did the physics
simulation of the oil paint yeah where
was that coral
that didn't do that
they
maybe not seven but like several years
ago
okay
so there's
definitely going to be a lot of like
duplicates and people researching the
same things so
um always true microsoft's
interest in like acquiring them and
working with them or like competing and
seeing who can do
who can reach the goal first
those are all just pragmatic business
decisions that get made by the people
who run those groups in the company
you know microsoft collaborates with
you know
thousands of companies we
buy companies big and small when it
seems like you know an appropriate and
mutually interesting thing to do
and you know some people think they just
would rather compete or we might decide
we could do better alone then we'll do
it so there's no fixed answer to that
question
and you know it's all largely driven by
economic analysis at the end of you know
how do you think you you win okay
um and the second one is
uh you were talking a lot about
um
like basically computers everywhere and
in the videos thing at the beginning
there was stuff like that as well so
i guess my question is um
where is like how are we going to power
all these devices
and
um are you thinking of
providing technology like
of the future to situations where
there's a lack of power or connectivity
because you were talking about like an
internet of devices and that kind of
thing
well
by if you mean power you're talking
about the electrical
source
i mean
i don't think that that's going to be
the big question i mean
you know any one of these computers
consumes a lot less energy than one
light bulb
so you know when people run around and
say hey i'm worried about all these
computers the first thing they should
ask themselves well why aren't you
worried about all those light bulbs all
right you know turn off a light bulb you
know or put an led thing in there you
can buy another computer so i personally
i and the reason i say that is we can we
continue to drive the energy consumption
computers lower and lower and lower and
lower
and so i just think that trend will
continue at both the data center scale
as well as the individual device scale
batteries you know are a chemistry
problem you know they're not going to
get better radically anytime soon so the
the quest for mobility you know really
forces you to drive the cost i mean the
the power consumption down on the
connectivity side that is a personal
interest i've had for 12 or 13 years and
in fact i took the initiative personally
and with the company to advocate for
regulatory changes globally and how
spectrum is allocated in order to be
able to
provide long-haul wi-fi is a simple way
to think about it and a lot of that was
in fact anticipating the need to provide
connectivity in in environments where
there just you know isn't any or isn't
any adequate or where the economics of
delivering it under conventional terms
like cellular systems is just not going
to be feasible and so you know it is an
area that i've invested a lot of time in
and we're having some success
yes sir um i'm curious you know
obviously these things that you showed
us today are so great and they're
they're there's so many positives to it
um but i think a lot of people would
argue that there also are a lot of
downsides you know this being connected
all the time and having your phone
constantly and your you know your tablet
and um so i guess i'm curious how
both personally and you know as a
representative of the only problem for
people with no willpower
so i guess you know i'm curious how you
see the potential downsides of
increasing technology the way we are and
you know whether you see you having a
role or a responsibility to sort of
mitigate some of these you know fears
that people might have
well i don't know whether i have a
responsibility to mitigate their fears i
think i have a responsibility to
to reflect in the products the needs of
the population
so
if
if you're right and people really decide
wow this is really bad you know we you
know we're too distracted while we're
driving or whatever it is my view is hey
we're just engineers give us the problem
we'll come up with a fix
all right so you know if a huge amount
of what we're doing now is to make
the
management of the computer's interaction
with you a lot more manageable i mean
part of the problem you've got right now
with all these devices in your life is
in fact they don't know about each other
all right and so you have the job of
essentially coordinating their action
you have the job of synchronizing their
their data sets or whatever is important
to you and you can't sort of ask them in
some
you know general way to like to change
their behavior or to modulate their
behavior based on what you're actually
doing
and so those are things that we are all
working on doing and you know my view is
we'll continue to make that just
naturally better it won't go crazy and
out of control
and to the extent that that any of that
gets out of hand the marketplace will
then favor the products that provide the
integral facilities to do that
management and and and so it turns out
that's that's that particular one is not
one that i
you know think will be any kind of
persistent problem so you're not worried
at all about you know when people say
that people don't interact as much face
to face or that sort of stuff you know
you don't think you think people will
want what they want and then once they
realize it's out of hand or if it ever
look i mean
whether people interact face to face you
can talk about sociological problems
but you know
you know i would tell you
that the isolation created by people
staring at televisions
was a much bigger problem
than quote the isolation it isn't really
isolation at all that that people are
now spending too much time interacting
with other people they're just doing it
in a computer-mediated way which was
worse
you know my view is hey you're a lot
better off you're at least communicating
with another human you know it may be in
some new way but you're not like you
know a couch potato sitting there
watching your tv screen
so i i personally tend to think that
these things are actually trending in a
positive direction and and yes we're
going to get different sociological
behaviors as as we adjust to that but
you know i think it's completely natural
and i have a lot of confidence in the
human species and its ability to adjust
to these things thank you
hi thanks for the talk is really
interesting um i had kind of a general
question uh kind of about the open
source and freeware technology that's
kind of out there right now
so in the past obviously all the stuff
was really accessible only by a very
small segment of like a
rarified set of very complex you know
advanced users but kind of the bar to
use some of these freeware technologies
has gone down a lot in recent years
to the point where you know now linux
distributions are pretty available
and some people are using those instead
of windows we have
a lot of people prefer r or python
programming languages to like matlab or
stata and people are using like
openoffice instead of office so it seems
like to me at least that there's kind of
becoming a split between
the advanced community which is using a
lot of this sort of open source freeware
and kind of the basic community so i
kind of two quick questions on that one
was
do you feel like that is sort of putting
a pressure on microsoft to
be designing more towards like sort of
the more common users rather than the
advanced power users and also in general
what your thoughts are on the open
source movement and
sort of the power of the global
developer base to create compelling
technologies for free
well
one initial reaction i have is i can
probably introduce you a lot of people
who don't who use proprietary products
who would not choose to refer to
themselves as basic
so i mean you know you got you have this
sort of elitist characterization of oh
there's us guys who can use that stuff
and everybody else is lesser people
i think that's a bad characterization
for starters
uh
that said i mean you know the idea that
there's free software is not new i mean
you know it's
goes
i mean when i started my company in 1983
we built an operating system on the
berkeley distribution of unix at the
time
and and so there's really nothing new
it's happening at a larger scale and you
could say it's accelerated simply
because of the degree of connectivity
that the world you know has available to
it now and with that you you know you
can get these collaborative efforts that
can take on some fairly significant
problems and make them available and you
know i think that that's all good i view
the whole thing as as sort of symbiotic
um it turned out if a company like
microsoft
tilted what it did
to say you know we're just going to
build products that would be better for
that
elite group of users then whatever they
can get out of the open source community
at any given minute in time we go broke
because there aren't really enough of
them you know in a world where we have
to serve you know a billion or two
people a year to put you know food on
the table
uh you know there just aren't enough
people you know if you're selling only
that class of products to to an elite
audience so we like to believe that
you know that that we can provide
technology for people who are elite
users and who choose to operate in the
framework that we provide but you know
we're very realistic about that you know
the new azure cloud facility at
microsoft one of the things that we've
put up on top of that is hadoop
you know what so we did the work to host
it in that environment so that people
who wanted to be able to rent that
capability in the context where it
worked with other microsoft related
products which you couldn't get if you
ran it yourself or put it in amazon aws
you know made it a lot easier
so you know there are many reasons that
people may choose to do that and many
practical reasons where microsoft may
take things that that community wants
and and sort of host it in our own
environment
you know the real
i'll say
challenge between the commercial world
and the
and the and the free software community
the tension really came
with the focus
uh
on the gpl you know 12 years ago
because
stallman's goal when he created that
license was in fact
to neuter the idea that there was any
commercial software
and you know and and so that really made
it a lot more difficult because
not only did it tend to prohibit people
who wanted to take it and build a
commercial derivative from doing so
directly but it took any commercial
company who who basically was doing
anything else it prohibited them in
practice from taking the stuff because
the license required in combination that
you give up all your rights to your own
product
and so you know i think that that that
one thing in the in the areas it was
applied to you know made the tension
higher than it had been for decades and
because you know that particular
operating system was popular
you know it
you know it's it it's an area where the
tension persists but i think in other
areas where people are using more like
the traditional bsd license
and you know the dozens of other you
know ones that people use
i think that there's a happy coexistence
long term between people who
want to be in the business of selling
software you know for value and and
people who say look i'm happy to
contribute my work for nothing
thanks
yes sir
last question all right so i mean you've
shown us a bunch of amazing technologies
here and you've said there are like 200
more currently underdeveloped at
microsoft research but obviously you
have to pick just a few if you want
people to actually be able to naturally
interact with their computers so
i mean i guess over your 20 years of
heading microsoft research how did you
make that decision that okay this is a
cool thing in the lab but i think it
could change the world and i think we
should push it forward to consumers
well
it turns out when you look at these
assets
in my mind the first thing you have to
do
is
decide what the scale
of their impact
is potentially
some of the things you know can be very
powerful but but they're in a very
narrow
domain of application
and so that's one natural filter you can
apply in terms of you know you don't
want to put
a huge amount of effort beyond something
that may be great but it has a limited
field of applicability
the other thing that that we try to
focus on
is
whether we can integrate things i mean
one of the greatest achievements of the
company recently and and certainly
microsoft research was connect
which was the
you know sound and vision sensor for
xbox and and now for
other applications
and the
you know
at least to this point despite its
popularity you know nobody else has
actually cloned to connect
and you say well why is that and the
answer is because
all of the key technologies and there
were multiple of them there were like
seven different classes of technology
that came out of msr all were done at
msr
and while you could go around the world
and find people who were working in each
of the seven different areas you
couldn't find any one place where people
understood how to make those things come
together
and and that doesn't mean they won't
eventually but
so when we look at things that are in an
important area and where we have
multiple ones that tend to reinforce
each other you know that's an area that
we tend to put more of an investment in
too
because it provides both novelty and
some sustainable uniqueness
simply because it's not one thing that
has to be copied it's many simultaneous
breakthroughs that have to be copied
and and that that's you know an
advantage and then the last is is i'll
say guided by
some high level
say guesses
as to what these major trends are going
to be so for example
it was
i want to say five or six years ago
where i think i actually coined the term
newey
and i said look you know that people had
talked about natural language and that
kind of stuff but you looked at what we
were doing and everybody else had done
and all we were doing was sort of
emulating these human senses one at a
time and then using it as an alternative
way to operate the graphical interface
and
and i said no i think that that there is
going to be a qualitative difference
if we could actually start to think of
natural interaction and applications
designed around that as a whole thing
and by raising that up
you know then a certain set of things in
msr that tended to
you know align with that as a as i'll
call it a corporate objective
sort of tend to rise up with it and you
get reinforcement
the same thing happened with machine
learning you know we said look this is
this is going to be a critical
technology we're going to use it in
virtually every part of the business
and so you know you you look around and
you basically collect those things and
and give them some reinforcement so a
lot of times at least at my level it's
not picking a project over another
project it's basically picking these
sort of macro directional statements
that you think are going to produce a
qualitative change across the company or
across the industry and then giving
rashid and the people who run research
you know the
the mandate to some extent to take their
big asset base and try to coalesce it in
order to accelerate our capability in
that specific area so i think that would
be how i would give you a direction
there thank you very much yep well thank
you to everyone i guess
thank you craig for coming and giving us
a fabulous demonstration